today we're going to talk about the 11
types of alopecia now what does the word
alopecia mean it comes from a greek word
uh alopex which means fox and the reason
why they talk about a fox is that
certain fox get an infection with mites
and they start losing their hair in
different patches
so that's the origin of the word
alopecia now as i go through this
there's a lot of new words that you may
not be familiar with just realize
they're mostly greek or latin words that
describe the characteristics of what's
happening with your hair so definitely
don't get caught up with the names just
classifications of different types of
hair loss now some of these conditions
that i'm going to talk about
are not really
a hair loss
problem
that's a symptom the underlying real
problem is the immune system
and so when someone has an autoimmune
condition they develop antibodies
against their own
tissues in certain types of alopecia you
have the body developing antibodies to
your own hair molecules and that creates
a loss of hair or some type of
thinning with the hair or damage with
the hair root or the hair just doesn't
grow other types of alopecia could have
a genetic component but don't get too
caught up in the genetics because
there's something called epigenetics
which is above your genes and so you can
do things about this even though you
have a genetic problem and then there's
a type of alopecia that is caused by too
much
dht which is a very powerful form of
testosterone so i'm definitely going to
get into the remedies
after i describe each type so let's
start with number one alopecia
areata okay now what does the word
ariata mean
comes from the latin word which means
area as in a vacant space or a patch
okay
so this is where you see
patches of hair loss throughout your
hair because of a certain autoimmune
disease now there are certain types of
alopecia areata that i'm going to
describe right now this is going to
include different patterns of hair loss
hair loss to your eyebrows hair loss to
different parts of your body but with
this condition there's usually a problem
with your t cells that's part of the
immune system your body has some type of
confusion and it's attacking the wrong
thing our own hair and so this general
type of alopecia areata can then get
worse
and
become alopecia ariatus totalis which
means that you have this
total hair loss in the top of your head
which i will get into in a minute or
alopecia ariata universalis
which is hair loss throughout the entire
body and the rest of the hair in your
body including your pubic hair and
axillary hair the hair underneath your
armpits and then the next type of
alopecia is called diffuse
alopecia
areata and sometimes referred as
incognita and don't ask me why they use
these incredibly long names maybe to
make them sound very very scientific so
in this diffuse type instead of having
patches of hair loss you have
areas that are very very thin so the
hair follicle is very very thin and it
looks like there's some patches then we
have the next type called alopecia
ariata ophiosis try to say that three
times
in this type you have hair loss on the
sides of the head as well as in the
lower back part of your skull this type
is uh really difficult to treat with
medications so
i would go with natural recommendations
which i'm going to get to okay so the
next one is called alopecia
this one is a loss of hair either on
your mustache or your beard this version
could also
occur with other types of hair loss as
well but it's very specific to the beard
and mustache area all right the next one
is called
androgenic
alopecia another name for this would be
pattern hair loss now normally hair
grows in these little groups between
three and four hairs and so with this
condition you're going to see those
little patches of hair or little groups
of hair start shrinking or atrophy and
so the number of hairs in these little
groups are going to get less and less
and less and eventually when they're
gone you're going to see more scalp than
you see here
and so androgenic alopecia
is
commonly known as male pattern hair loss
but you also have women pattern hair
loss too and this is the most common
cause of hair loss
in fact 50 of men over the age of 50
have this condition and 50 of women over
the age of 65 start developing this
condition and so in a man you'll see
receding hair loss right through here
and then a loss of hair on the top part
of the head
and with women you'll see more just
thinning on the top part of the head all
right this next one has a very long name
so we're just going to call it
ccca okay just to make it really simple
so this type involves scarring on the
top of your head this is most common in
women that have an african descent and
adding some vitamin e oil in fact
massaging that into the scalp can be a
great thing to help break down some of
the scar tissue and also provide more
oxygen stimulation to the scalp but the
problem is if it's there too long the
scar tissue
could get to the point where it's it's
permanent it's irreversible all right
the next one is called frontal fibrosin
alopecia this one involves the sideburns
and the frontal part of your head this
mostly involves menopausal females but
it can also affect men as well so with
this you're going to see a lot of
receding
the hair through here due to scar tissue
some people may lose their eyebrows or
eyelashes with this condition all right
the next one is called traction
alopecia and this occurs because there's
strain or stress and the hair roots it
usually occurs when people have these
very tight hairstyles
so you have people who are using braids
dreadlocks or a ponytail or even using
certain chemical relaxers that can
weaken the hair so this constant
traction
actually pulls the hair right on the
scalp and the last one is called
chemotherapy induced alopecia
unfortunately the chemicals that use in
cancer therapy
destroy not just the immune system they
can destroy
different parts of your body including
the roots of your hair but as soon as
the chemotherapy is stopped the hair
should come back given the right
nutrition the person's on and the
overall health of the immune system now
i do want to say one thing about
chemotherapy anytime someone goes
through chemotherapy it's very very
important for them to also do
intermittent fasting and periodic
prolonged fasting
the fasting can greatly reduce the side
effects from chemotherapy as well as
radiation therapy all right so at this
point let's talk about some really good
remedies that i would recommend if you
have any of these type of alopecia
issues number one rosemary oil is a
really great
natural oil to rub into your scalp
each night before you go to bed
there's certain properties in rosemary
oil that are
great for many different types of
alopecia issues and as a side note
castor oil
is good for the loss of your eyebrows
now there's a lot of things you can also
use
like onion juice and garlic oil and
green tea of course don't put it on your
scalp hot but wait till it cools down
and you can rub into your scalp but
there's many different herbal extracts
that can help stimulate the growth of
hair but in this list there are seven
things i'm going to talk about one is
the rosemary oil okay number two is
taking a really good probiotic why
because in many autoimmune conditions it
starts in your gut your gut becomes too
permeable it's called leaky gut and you
have the entire immune system right
behind the barrier
and certain things get in there and you
start creating
all sorts of issues with immune wise
so a probiotic is very important
especially if you have a history of gut
problems that occurred just before you
start developing this hair issue i
always recommend to get a clue on what's
causing your hair loss is just to look
back
in time and find out what occurred just
before you started to develop this
condition and it could be any condition
at all any body problem there's always
something right before this that
triggered it it could be a severe
stress like a loss of a loved one which
by the way is behind a lot of autoimmune
diseases so this gives you information
to help you
try to undo some of the damage based on
what caused it if it was a stress
trigger then you can work on doing all
sorts of things to improve stress
both food wise environmentally and
certain supplements all right number
three zinc zinc is
essential if you have any immune issues
at all number four vitamin d
vitamin d and zinc for any immune
problems is very very important vitamin
d is an immune modulator it is the best
remedy for any autoimmune condition i've
done a lot of videos on this and i would
recommend taking
nothing less than 10 000 ius but
probably 20 or 30 000 ius of vitamin d
every single day all right the next one
is using an infrared type treatment on
your scalp there's a lot of new
devices coming out that are like little
helmets that you put over your head the
infrared spectrum of light energy
is really good to help reduce androgenic
type problems with the hair because
what's happening is we have this enzyme
that's converting more free testosterone
to dht which is a very powerful form of
testosterone and that's burning the hair
out and so anything that you can do to
interfere with that
process is a good thing and there's a
lot of herbal things you can take too
like salt palmetto stinging nettle root
but the infrared
light on your scalp
has been shown to create some
significant improvement in your hair all
right so the next one and we fasting you
need to be doing intermittent fasting
okay and definitely periodic prolonged
fasting fasting for autoimmune
conditions to drop inflammation
for any genetic problems or weaknesses
is
dynamite as far as the effectiveness in
helping you put this thing back in
remission because we can never say cure
we'll just say put it back in remission
fasting is probably one of the most
powerful epigenetic things you can do
especially if you have a genetic
predisposition to
any condition all right the last thing
is reducing your stress i've already
mentioned that but there are many many
things you can do to pull yourself out
of this stress state i'm talking about a
chronic stress situation where you're
stuck between a rock and a hard place it
could be either environmental where
you're in an environment where there's a
lot of stress or
you had a severe loss there are many
things you can do in fact i want to put
up probably one of the most important
videos i've done on stress
right here so check that out
you